you welcome to this video playing
jogador from the netherlands so let's
get going yeah handle fact if you watch
the video before that which should have
been released them yesterday compared to
this release date you notice the rating
the period I lost or 20 points and it's
quite fun how I lost that because gap
sometimes you're just stupid I am I
actually play them a little bit of
bullet yesterday and at one point there
are those buttons that you can click
here for one minute three minute five
minute and at one point I accidentally
click the five-minute button and a five
minute game was started and i was still
dashing out those yeah quick moves for
bullet better wouldn't is this guy
taking so no then i looked at the clock
there and I I had played the first
couple of moves instantly but in the
process I had made some terrible mistake
I you you kind of dash out stuff here
and bullet and I couldn't really come
back from that it totally destroyed me
so I was a pretty crazy wave to lose a
lose rating points okay while telling
this story we set up a kind of an
unconventional opening here um yeah she
going Todd quite sure why I went III
actually just just dash this out a
little bit maybe sun bullet mode from
yesterday yeah III is not completely
useless but it was more waiting I was
thinking Bishop d3 is not not doing much
okay so i can take now here i can take e
for now this is interesting that looks a
little bit like done yeah maybe this it
looks a little bit like the Lasker
variation of the Queens gambit declined
but he has a knight on c6 which is not
really not really that um
appropriate okay I'm checking with the
Queen I mean be takes would have given
the pawn but also I want to have a look
at them the e5 square so that this break
isn't so easily possible okay he can
still not play it as d 5 is hanging and
if he takes first I'm checking with the
Queen so that after if I have d5 and
Irwin c7 it's not so easy to get this
get this break-in so what about this
simple way is just to take it take you 5
i'm in very can take actually imply
queen bee three how is he covering d5
and a five okay it's sorry d 5 NB 7 this
is what I'm trying to say a five was
coming to mind her oh it was in my mind
that Knight a5 movement I can just take
d 5 so this is this is a pawn or has a
subject technical way to defend this
don't see it at the moment okay Queen B
7 is something that is not me okay we
cannot really go rugby 8 as i take c 7
and everything is falling falling apart
okay so i'm taking b7 now what is this
hmm there's no reason no real reason not
to I guess Knight a5 is useless route be
aight i take a six even and this is
never enough for black you can take be
too but um there are some additional
problems yeah Bishop b5 is one of them
let's have a look at this setting up
this this pin
it's not a pin but it's attacking the
the night and bit inconvenient just
wonder if I'm doing that what is he
playing and night night XD for I check
on g4 with the night you can take a b5
Queen B 5 night XD form yeah that's a
possibility Queen to d3 maybe night at
3g takes bishop age three this is a bit
tricky actually that's a bit tricky not
sure if I like it that much maybe I have
something else that is a bit a bit
simpler just you could be one maybe yeah
I'm already upon up I don't need to do
something so fancy and in fancy is the
wrong word for Bishop b5 but it's mean I
already have a partner so I don't need
to be greedy fnc what's wrong word
greedy is the right one don't need to be
greedy here ok so here I can just take
on be tool that didn't help much ok
let's still do that if I go Bishop b5
now 94 is not working but the whole
thing the whole combination now is not
it's not playable I have Queen a8 also
after any kind of like a loop b5 queen
bee 595 queen bee a check and then I
take it so there is no tactic I think
and I'd like to check on c6 getting rid
of the getting rid of the night um yeah
it's Knight e5
95 now come on let's just take this is
simple and good that just leads to a
good end game even if I'm losing the a3
pawn it's a very comfortable ending okay
three yep maybe you can go rugae three
there's no no real problem however I can
play I cannot do that where do I go
maybe here I have to check on v8 and 95
that's quite nice check I can go look a
age maybe and kick me back and that's
actually a good move
okay i have quincy two wins a little
threat oh okay check that was nice and
very healthy I had the better end game
there because my night is just stronger
than this bishop in this very static
position but um ok so let's have a look
here yeah I plant them the Chi Goren
normally black it's not playing e 6 2
transpose on to some kind of Queens
gambit declined where the night is
slightly strange on c6 normally they
take here for more dynamic play and
something like a for Bishop g4 attacking
the center here with with peace pressure
six yeah now it's likely Queens gambit
declined with the knight on c6 which is
I mean not great but but it's also not
like losing i mean black is still fairly
fairly okay um when aged six kept it and
a 6cm platia a3 quite routinely it
wasn't matter of I would didn't want to
go here because night before looked a
bit annoying I need to move that Bishop
again then and I wanted to go to be
three not to eat you so I went here
quickly to prepare the move but huh now
it's probably okay night you form and
the Straits things maybe you could have
considered to take with this interesting
try to UM still have the option of
playing the sea palm if I take now okay
the night is maybe not ideal here in
this structure but well it's not so bad
black white often gets in a five in this
kind of this kind of situation okay so
this was quite quite logical I think we
should be yeah
and Brooke said yeah now the question is
a slow move or what I did I try to
really am get to the pawn well it seems
fine a computer agrees that white is
quite substantially better Queen here
Queen B seven degrees with that yeah I
now okay rupee one is even right yeah
the thing that I didn't like about this
move was ok yeah it was a good game it
seems the count agree said this isn't
clear that's good that's good I actually
overlooked something I think my line was
this I was thinking here I saw this and
this didn't seem clear to me as he as
any check on the G file is deadly I'm I
have to keep the rook otherwise it
doesn't make any sense and I didn't
calculate further but the computer gives
this and black is almost winning yeah
this is here okay that was a good
calculation then that Bishop b5 wasn't
right and rugby one is actually given as
the best move and Bishop b5 so I was
good yeah my plate plated ok well now
I'm missing something yeah I'm okay I
was my idea was that okay like I'm
better any also ever I'm better even if
i'm giving away upon a three but there's
no need i can go a form which is quite a
simple movement and this is far better
i'm just keeping the pawn yeah this is a
much worse in comparison and here oh I
could have taken a three I didn't think
about that that's of course very strong
asked you put I'm stupid I could have
taken here this is this a lot of
material for the for the Queen in fact
this is quite quite an easy win because
those pawns they will be taken by my
pieces very very easily okay you can
play c5 p.m. 22 to trade one off but I'm
winning this yeah just by regrouping
Bishop 2g to pick that up and then I'm
winning porn after pawn
yeah that said that would have been even
stronger lot stronger actually check
yeah here here here I'm better but it's
not like a morning so um yeah yeah
auntie gin with this piece but if he
doesn't do that um let's say he goes
here I have had a quite nice and
substantially better end game I think
it's also better than what the computer
is giving it just gives 0.5 about four
wide but I think it's more than that
because it's very uncomfortable all
those phones keep keeper being weak and
it's it's what you sometimes get out of
the the cows but variation and the
minority attack kind of scenario is very
nice position where that you can well
play on forever torture black but of
course I could have one much more yeah
could have played much more decisively
earlier ok I hope you enjoyed this
thanks for watching